[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen Fußball und
Tennis gibt's heute von Sven Foss guten
Abend auf diese Themen schauen wir
ausführlich drogebärde gegen Israel der
Chef der libanesischen Hisbollah Miliz
äußert sich erstmals seit dem
Terrorangriff durch die
Hamas
migrationstreffen im Kanzleramt in
offenbar konstruktiver Atmosphäre beredt
Scholz mit den Spitzen der
Unionsfraktion über die
Asylpolitik und eintauchen ins alte
Ägypten die Geschichte des kindkönigs
tut anjamun als multimediaspektakel in
Hamburg die Sorge ist groß dass sich der
Krieg zwischen Israel und der Hamas auf
den Libanon ausweitet bereits jetzt
beschießt die libanesische terrormiliz
hbolla immer immer wieder den Norden
Israels heute hat sich erstmals seit
Kriegsbeginn Hisbollah Chef Hassan
nasralla offiziell zu Wort gemeldet
bundesaußenministerin berborg warnte die
Miliz vor einem großangelegten Angriff
auf Israel die schitische hisbolla
existiert seit 1982 im Libanon als
politische Partei
Sozialorganisation aber vor allem als
hochgerüstete Miliz finanziert von Iran
die Zahl der Kämpfer wird auf rund 50
000 geschätzt us berechnen ihr Arsenal
auf etwa 150 000 Raketen
entsprechend selbstbewusst heute das
Auftreten des hisbolla Führers nasrala
goline
berichtet symbolreich hatte Libanons
mächtige hisbolla Miliz die Spannung
gesteigert mit propagandavos über ihren
Führer Hassan nassalla sollte die Welt
heute eine Kriegserklärung
hören einige tausend Anhänger in Beirut
schauten nasralla auf einer Leinwand zu
er tritt nur selten öffentlich auf
zunächst nahm er seine Miliz in Schutz
und seinen Verbündeten den Iran der
Kriegszug der Hamas so nennt er den
Terrorangriff das sei ausschließlich
eine palästinensische Heldentat
gewesen Botschaft Nummer 2 die
Nadelstiche der Hisbollah tägliche
Drohnen und Raketenangriffe an der
Grenze zu Israel hätten Wirkung gezeigt
der Feind werde so erfolgreich abgelenkt
er habe ein Drittel Seer Streitkräfte
aus Gaza abziehen
müssen dann droht nasralla zumindest
indirekt alle Möglichkeiten an der
libanesischen Front sind offen alle
Optionen liegen auf dem Tisch und können
jederzeit ergriffen werden wir müssen
alle vorbereitet sein bereit sein für
alle zukünftigen
Möglichkeiten die Gefolgschaft
antwortete genauso wie der
milizführer is weiter an der Grenze
angreift werden wir natürlich Antworten
und
zurückschlagen weite Teile der Rede
folgten dem klassischen Textbuch der
hisboll der Hauptfeind sei die USA
weitere Angriffe proiranischer Milizen
auf amerikanische Militärstützpunkte in
der Region sein
gewiss und gol und LP sind mir jetzt
zugeschaltet beide sind für uns im Nahen
Osten zuerst zu
ihn Rede des hisboll Chefs einzuschätzen
was eine mögliche weitere Kriegsfront
gegen Israel
angeht der Berg kreiste und gebar eine
Maus so der spittische Kommentar vieler
Beobachter in der Region eine Reaktion
auf eine Rede die doch als möglicher
Wendepunkt im Verlauf des Krieges
angekündigt worden war aber die Rede
blieb den noch sehr sehr vorsichtig
hassanasralla versuchte in dieser Rede
die Hamas und die Hisbollah voneinander
zu trennen und damit auch auch seine
Männer aus der Schusslinie zu nehmen
obwohl es doch einige Belege gibt die
darauf hindeuten dass der 7 Oktober
gemeinsam von diesen Gruppen geplant
worden ist und Beobachtung Nummer 2 die
roten Linien die blieben in dieser Rede
selsam verschwommen sicher man werde
mobilisieren wenn die Hamas um ihre
Existenz Kämpfe aber wann genau das sei
das blieb offen die hisbolla bleibt also
im wartemodus kann man sagen sicher ist
es so bei der hisbolla Worte das eine
und taten das andere aber das was wir
heute hörten das klang eher nicht nach
einer Kriegserklärung dann bcken wir mal
nach Tel Aviv zu ihn l walpot wie sind
die Reaktion aus Israel auf die Rede des
isbolla
Chefs Regierungschef Netanyahu hat sich
jedenfalls nicht beeindruckt gezeigt er
hat noch einmal darauf hingewiesen dass
es für ihn keine Feuerpause keine
Waffenpause geben wird in Gaza man halte
weiter an dem Ziel fest jedenfalls
solange die Geiseln dort in Händen der
Hamas sind gibt es keine Feuerpause
sagte Netanyahu das Ziel ist klar Hamas
vernichten die Sicherheit Israels
wiederherstellen und eben ganz V zu
vorders diese Geiseln lebend aus Gaza
herausbekommen er hat zugleich auch eine
Warnung in Richtung Libanon geschickt an
nasralla
diesen Konflikt nicht weiter eskalieren
zu lassen und die israelische Presse
verweist noch mit Entrüstung und
Empörung darauf dass nasralla das äh ja
das Abschlachten von
1400 Zivilisten hier in Israel als
heldenhafte Operation gelobt hat die
Hamas Massaker also quasi verherrlicht
hat und gesagt hab es die Hamas hätte
gar keine Massaker verübt dass so nasral
in seiner Rede hätten die israelische
Armee gemacht das wird dann hier doch
mit Empörung aufgenommen diese Umkehr
von Täter und Opfer l wepot und goline
atai danke schön für diese
Einordnung
israel hat seine Staatsangehörigen
aufgefordert aus Sicherheitsgründen
Auslandsreisen zu überdenken
Bundeskanzler Scholz und der jordanische
König Abdullah haben wegen des Krieges
telefoniert und eine zweist
staatenlösung für Israelis und
Palästinenser gefordert so ein
Regierungssprecher und auch
usaußenminister blinken setzt seine
diplomatischen Bemühungen fort Tim
Kröger die Bodenoffensive der
israelischen Armee im Gazastreifen geht
unvermindert in der Nacht habe es erneut
heftige Gefechte gegeben diese Bilder
sollen ein der hamasunnel zeigen von
denen es in Gaza ein ganzes Netz geben
soll am Morgen traf US Außenminister
blinken in Israel ein und kam mit
Ministerpräsident Benjamin netanahu
zusammen er plierte für die zwei
staatenlösung sicherte dem Land das
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung zu forderte
aber auch einen besseren Schutz für die
Zivilbevölkerung in
Gaza wir glauben dass diese Bemühungen
dur eine
ermögl werden mit Absprachen vor Ort die
die Sicherheit für Zivilisten erhöhen
und effektivere und dauerhafte
humanitäre Hilfe
ermöglichen Ministerpräsident netanahu
knüpft eine Feuerpause jedoch an
Bedingungen ich habe klar gemacht dass
wir mit ganzer Kraft fortfahren und dass
Israel eine temporäre Feuerpause ablehnt
die nicht die Freilassung der Geisel
beinhaltet am grenzübergangfach warten
noch immer verletzte und Menschen mit
ausländischen Pässen auf ihre Ausreise
darunter auch
deutsche wir sind hier seit 13 Tage hier
ist es schwierig hier ist kein Wasser
kein kein Essen kein Strom ist nichts
wir leben einfach wie alten Zeit wie
alte Steine Zeit nach palästinensischen
Angaben hat Israel außerdem damit
begonnen tausende Arbeiter die nach dem
7 oktober in Israel festsaßen in den
Gasastreifen
zurückzubringen und vor wenigen Minuten
hat das Auswärtige Amt mitgeteilt dass
heute mehr als 30 deutsche den
Gazastreifen verlassen konnten darunter
auch Familien mit
Kindern enger Verbündeter Israels sind
die USA Schutzmacht und wichtiger
Geldgeber zugleich nun sind aber wegen
eines innenpolitischen Streits
Milliarden schwere Hilfszahlungen an
Israel blockiert das Repräsentantenhaus
in dem die Republikaner eine Mehrheit
haben bewilligte zwar ein Paket in Höhe
von 14 Milliarden Dollar es aber an
Bedingungen das lehnen die Demokraten ab
sodass der Entwurf im Senat keine
Mehrheit bekommen wird wegen des Streits
liegen auch Zahlungen an die Ukraine auf
Eis nach Deutschland da hat sich Kanzler
Scholz heute mit Unionsfraktion Chef
märz und CSU landesgruppenchef Dobrind
getroffen die Themen Asyl und Migration
am kommenden Montag wird es dazu auch
einen Bund ländergipfel geben aus dem
Umfeld von März hieß es das Gespräch
heute im Kanzleramt sei sehr gut und die
Atmosphäre sachlich und konstruktiv
gewesen ein Bericht von Karl
Hinterleitner fast drei Stunden hatten
sie zusammengesessen was Friedrich MZ
und Alexander dobrin mit dem
Bundeskanzler bei ihrem vertraulichen
Austausch besprochen haben blieb
vertraulich kein Kommentar die
Forderungen der Union formulierten
andere das fängt an mit der Kürzung der
Sozialleistung es hängt damit zusammen
dass der Familiennachzug drastisch
reduziert wird dass wir zum la
Sachleistungsprinzip übergehen dass wir
Grenzkontrollen machen es ist muss raus
aus dem parteipolitischen klein klein
einer Koalition in Berlin die sich nicht
einigen kann Bund und Länder kommen am
Montag zum migrationsgipfel zusammen zu
erwarten ist Streit ums Geld die Länder
wollen mehr Unterstützung aus Berlin und
besonders die Kommunen sehen sich bei
den Kosten für die Unterbringung von
geflüchteten überlastet wir haben bis 21
eine Regelung gehabt nachdem der Bund
die Unterkunftskosten flüchtlingsbedingt
getragen hat die Ampel hat sich davon
verabschiedet und das kann nicht sein
weil wir als Kommunen keinen Einfluss
darauf haben wie viele Menschen nach
Deutschland kommen dass wir mit diesen
Kosten alleinelassen werden Stefan weil
SPD Ministerpräsident von Niedersachsen
warnt die Bundespolitik in einem
Zeitungsinterview meinte weil wir müssen
etwas tun für den Zusammenhalt in der
Gesellschaft und es bereitet mir große
Sorge dass dieser Zusammenhalt
gegenwärtig Schaden nimmt die Länder
sind sich ihrer Verantwortung sehr
bewusst wir erwarten das auch von den
Beteiligten in
Berlin ein parteiübergreifender Konsens
bei der Migration das ist das Ziel des
bundländergipfels am Montag es dürften
lange Gespräche werden Diana Zimmermann
aus unserem Hauptstadtstudio warum
versucht der Kanzler die Opposition
einzubinden na der Kanzler möchte dass
die Opposition Verantwortung übernimmt
er möchte damit auch den Wählern
signalisieren si her bei diesem großen
Problem der Migration arbeiten alle
großen demokratischen Parteien zusammen
an der Lösung Vorschläge gibt es
inzwischen viele tatsächlich wird an
vielen kleinen Stellschrauben gedreht
das wird auch am Montag mit den
Ministerpräsidenten diskutiert das
Problem ist eine schnelle Entlastung der
Kommunen ist nicht zu erwarten
bestenfalls mittelfristig wird dieses
Paket zu einer Entlastung führen und die
Frage ist daher warum sollte die
Opposition da mitmachen die Antwort wäre
aus gesellschaftspolitischer
Verantwortung die Gefahr aber ist dass
eben das Projekt scheitert und die Union
dann mit diesem Scheitern auch nach
Hause geht märz und doberin haben von
einem konstruktiven treffen gesprochen
das signalisiert Gesprächsbereitschaft
die Verantwortung für dieses riskante
Projekt scheinen sie aber noch nicht
übernehmen zu wollen vielen Dank Diana
Zimmermann die Gewerkschaften haben
Warnstreiks im öffentlichen Dienst der
Länder angekündigt zuvor war die zweite
Runde der Tarifgespräche ohne Ergebnis
geblieben verhandelt wird für alle
Länder mit Ausnahme Hessens wann und wo
gestreigt wird ließen werdi und
Beamtenbund offen sie fordern 10,5% mehr
Geld mindestens aber 500 € mehr pro
Monat die Länder sagen das sei viel zu
hoch und nicht
finanzierbar in die Ukraine im Osten des
Landes haben die russischen Angriffe
stark zugenommen vor allem in den
vergangenen Tagen in mehreren Orten im
Großraum Haak fordern die Behörden
Familien mit Kindern auf die Region zu
verlassen aus kubansk berichtet unser
Reporter Dara Hassan Sade die Stadt war
bis September 2022 von russischen
Truppen
besetzt wir fahren nach kupjansk die
Stadt hat schwer gelitten in diesem
Krieg wir sind mit einem Offizier der
ukrainischen Armee verabredet und die
Front verlaufe so zeigt uns der Offizier
nur wenige Kilometer entfernt unten im
Tal eine russische Offensive drohe auch
hier er will unerkannt bleiben
wir sind vorbereitet wir haben
Positionen angelegt und deren
Verteidigung geprobt wir rechnen mit
Angriffen wie in bachmut
oderdivka wir wissen nicht ob der Feind
die gleichen Szenarien wiederholen wird
falls ja dann wird er uns damit nicht
überraschen russland hat große
Truppenverbände zusammengezogen der
Fluss erdient als letzte ukrainische
Verteidigungslinie vor kopjansk von
ehemals 6000 Einwohnern sind noch etwa 5
bis 6000 hier für Familien mit Kindern
gilt eine Zwangsevakuierung geht es nach
der Militärverwaltung sollten alle
gehen sie riskieren ihr Leben und wir
haben viele Situationen in denen
Menschen die in den frontstädten Leben
und in den Dörfern die nahe der Front
sind verletzt werden oder
sterben trotz der Gefahr wollen meist
ältere Menschen Heimatstadt nicht
verlassen wie diese Frauen sie haben
erst vor kurzem eine Art caff eröffnet
wenn wir alle gehen sagen Sie uns dann
stirbt doch unsere
Stadt Sturmtief kiren zieht gerade über
Europa besonders heftig haben die
Ausläufer der Nacht Italien getroffen in
der Toscana starben mindestens fünf
Menschen Behörden sprechen von
Regenmengen wie seit zwei Jahrhunderten
nicht ganze Landstriche standen unter
wasserus haushal waren ohne Strom in der
tosana wurde der Notstand ausgerufen
auch im Norden Italiens mussten die
Rettungskräfte in der Nacht mit
schlauchboten ausrücken um
eingeschlossene zu
retten der Mythos tutanchamon fasziniert
Millionen Menschen seit das Grab des
Pharaos vor mehr als 100 Jahren entdeckt
wurde unzielige Bücher Ausstellung
Dokumentation haben sich seitdem mit dem
Jugendlichen Gottkönig und seiner Zeit
beschäftigt jetzt kann man tut auch
virtuell nahekommen über das 3D Event in
Hamburg berichtet Petra
Meyer er scheint direkt auf die Besucher
zuzukommen der Junge Pharao tut anch
Amun mit der weltberühmten goldenen
Maske seine Welt vor 3300 Jahren sie
wird im digitalen Raum rund um den
Besucher lebendig ein Zeitsprung hinein
in das fantastische alte Ägypten weil
man wirklich Hal das Gefühl man ist drin
in der gesamten Sache und das ist
hochemotional die Käfer und die die
Geckos das war nicht so meine Sache aber
ja sehr sehr schöne Bilder sehr
interessant spannt und man hat sich
irgendwie so mittendrin gefühlt die
Ausstellung nur möglich weil der Brite
Howard Carter das Grab des kaum
bekannten kindparaos vor 101 Jahren im
Tal der Könige entdeckt und aufwendige
Skizzen des
sensationsfundsmacht die unvorstellbare
Pracht der Grabstätte der Grabbeigaben
machen tut am zum ägyptischen Superstar
doch erforscht sind die
Originalfundstücke bisher
kaum mask die Maske z.B ist eine der
bekanntesten Objekte im Grab von
tutanchamon sie wurde aber bis heute
nicht wissenschaftlich analysiert das
ist
unfassbar der altägyptische Totenkult
wird per Virtual Reality Brille lebendig
die Besucher folgen dem Weg des kaum
volljährig Verstorbenen Pharao ins
Totenreich der digital tutch Amun
hautnah und doch weiter
rätselhaft interessante Themen und
aktuell Information haben wir auch in
unserem Onlineangebot ZDF heute die
Nachrichtenlage gibt es jetzt ganz neu
auch bei Whatsapp scannen Sie dafür
einfach den angezeigten QR-Code oder
abonnieren Sie uns direkt bei Whatsapp
selbst alles Wichtige kompakt für Sie
zusammengefasst und jetzt kommen wir zum
Fußball im Pokal sind die Bayern in der
Liga steht das Spitzenspiel an sen und
da will der FC Bayern morgen eine
Reaktion zeigen gegen Dortmund beide
Teams sind noch ungeschlagen der Sieger
bleibt an Tabellenführer Leverkusen dran
das letzte Duell gewann die Bayern
deutlich mit 4 Z2 Tuchels erstes Spiel
für die Bayern im April gleich ein Sieg
gegen den BVB Tuchels letztes Spiel
bekanntermaßen weniger zum Jubeln die
Blamage im Pokal gegen den Drittligisten
aus saücken haben Mannschaft der wie vor
Vertrauen und und wir fahren morgen nach
Dortmund um Spiel zu gewinnen viele
Stammspieler verletzt zul letetzt
Abwehrchef der Licht dazu die Rotsperre
für Kimmich die Aufstellung wird zum
Puzzle wenigstens ke ist frisch der kam
im Pokal ja gar nicht zum Einsatz die
zuletzt stabilen Dortmunder schöpfen aus
ihrem breiten Kader gewinnen ist
wichtiger als schön zu spielen aber die
Bayern sind ein Angstgegner gegen uns
sind sind ihre Sinne eh immer ein
bisschen geschärfter als vielleicht
gegen den einen oder anderen Gegner in
der Bundesliga aber besonders jetzt
kommt wahrscheinlich noch eine kleine
Portion Wut mit dazu vielleicht setzt es
ja nur auf diese Weise Prügel für die
bayn in
Dortmund die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft
koplenz hat ein Verfahren gegen
mainzprofi Anwar elgasi eingeleitet es
bestehe der Anfangsverdacht von
Volksverhetzung durch verbreiten eines
Inhalts elgazi war nach einem israelf
feindlichen Post vorübergehend
suspendiert worden vor einer Stunde hat
Mainz 05 den Vertrag mit dem Spieler
endgültig auf
gelöst daniel altmeierer ist beim
tennismasters in Paris ausgeschieden er
verlor gegen Titelverteidiger Holger
ruhne der Däne wird unterstützt von
einer deutschen
tennisikone wenn Boris Becker wieder so
am tenniskord auftaucht dann ist er
zurück als Trainer sein Schützling den
er nach dessen Krisen motivierte denne
Holger Ruhe Nummer 7 der Welt dunkles
Trikot und der 20 Jahre alte
Titelverteidiger bezwingt überlegen den
deutschen Daniel Altmeier bei Masters in
Paris im Achtelfinal
[Applaus]
und
Gegner dener auch schon mal
trainiert und das war der freitagssport
danön die Blätter hängen noch an den
Bäumen die Temperaturen sind mild oder
um es anders auszudrücken es sind noch 7
Wochen bis Weihnachten trotzdem können
sich offenbar viele nicht früh genug in
Stimmung bringen wie hier in Essen haben
mehrere Weihnachtsmärkte eröffnet
Lebkuchen glitzerketten und
Paradiesäpfel Anfang November und für
den Essener gilt er ist nicht nur einer
der frühsten sondern ein einer der
längsten bis kurz vor Silvester kann man
das Fest dann ausklingen
lassen morgen wird sehr windig wo genau
das erfahren Sie von Christa Orben das
heute journal läuft an diesem Abend um
22 Uhr mit Christian sieers einen
schönen Freitagabend wünsche ich
[Musik]
ihn
guten Abend der Herbst ist spürbar in
Fahrt gekommen jetzt wird es erst einmal
ruhiger bevor uns morgen dann das
nächste Sturmtief erreicht und das sorgt
in Westeuropa und mit seiner Kilometer
langen Front auch im Mittelmeerraum
erneut für gefährlich stürmische
Verhältnisse bei uns wird es in der
Nacht aber ruhiger es ist verbreitet
trocken das Regengebiet das in den Alpen
heute ordentlich Schnee brachte zieht
Ost wärts ab die Temperaturen sinken auf
8 bis 4° im Süden auf 4 bis -3° über
Schnee und bei Aufklaren am Alpenrand
also morgen früh frostig morgen liegen
die Höchstwerte zwischen 7° im Vogtland
und 13° in der Niederlausitz vormittags
gibt es im Osten und im Süden noch
einiges an Sonnenschein im Südwesten
kündigen dichtere Wolken die Regenfront
an und die verbreitet sich nachmittags
dann schnell nach Osten hinaus wo der
Regen ankommt wird es stürmisch in
Berglagen sind orkanartige böhnen dabei
vorsicht also vor umstürzenden Bäumen
und herabfallenden Gegenständen am
Sonntag wird es noch mal etwas
stürmischer im Süden und in der Mitte
vorsicht also hier auch die neue Woche
startet mit sehr viel Wind und
wechselhaft genießen Sie aber trotzdem
den Herbst
tschüss